so I honestly kind of feel like I was
probably supposed to do something mmm
what's this nothing okay he's looking at
it why is he looking at it what is it
explain yourself get to do that money I
hope that happens for you men he's
looking here - okay so apparently when
he tilts his head out
there's relevant however I only just
figured that out all right so what did
that guy go city or a second ago I feel
like I would have noticed is huge but
leaving but I feel like I need to find a
way to get in to that that red pipe is
the one in that dude's room and I think
that's I need to get a message from
there somehow so all right I'm I screwed
that up somehow I need to convince that
guy to let me in there to fix it or
something I need to do the worms thing
again that's goo okay but get some orbs
and bladder don't buy them actually
wouldn't that suck he's looking up there
because so much we didn't get bonuses
that year Daniels uh-huh I only just
noticed this things he stares at you can
interact with oh let's just walk the
whole way up here and back to get some
dead one he's looking this way now what
are you looking at I just pressed X and
he's walking himself over there now what
is it
the buds maybe I can give them bread
let's try that you want this oh so maybe
I can use bread on but somehow that
seems if I just use bread maybe I have
to leave it for them somewhere but I
don't know why I'm okay maybe that's
late I don't know why I wouldn't need
that why I wouldn't need bread and hoods
and do we have any worms left mm-hmm
just a brick hmm hey buddy
dead worms so lucky
can I have two I want two dead ones
before okay so I can't interact with
things while I'm holding something is
what it is I can't talk to him when I'm
holding something else
okay and here we go
let's do it
ah right it's very sunny in the land of
the dead though
actually you know I should probably pull
my cat out I could be in serious danger
there we go foof
thank God I remembered I was probably
really close to death you know yeah it's
probably a car there head oh my god that
way come ooon he looks up again oh no no
just shake you a little cat out that'll
do okay all right
yes I can't open the door with the cat
in my hand which doesn't make any sense
money how are you gonna be protective
when you open the door if you won't hold
the cat while you're doing it God okay
dead one time and the other one for the
red yes all right
so yeah I feel like it's also let me do
this twice because I am I guess a lot of
people screw this up which makes me feel
a lot better about myself
now I'm gonna pay attention to the way
that his head moves are you looking okay
yeah elevator that makes sense I too
like to look at elevators
Oh herb it doesn't tell you like that's
where I'm supposed to go it doesn't know
I think he just looks at everything that
he can possibly look at how are you
doing to cut in a fight I think any good
you gotta go hit the bricks I love that
they have like a little backstory for
like a Christmas party like it's amazing
okay
then y'all there we go and break the
pipes again man I feel so sorry for that
the guy who looks after them could be a
bad day for him pull a little thing okay
number one now much more like a dildo of
and a worm and then worm number two yes
success number two
uh-huh
sweet so this down again roughly should
stop doing it yeah you dick okay he
looks at stuff here we read the old
files huh it'll just make me sad
well what's that no why did you that's
strange I did not mean to do that I just
pressed X and he like walks the entire
way back around that sounds reasonable
yeah I feel like there was something
like maybe I'm thinking that that could
be something to pick up over here so
he's looking at books right I'm already
did now Rena Marie didn't help no no
wait the deck of cards is out put it
away put you down deck of cards away
read I'm already these hooks instead I'm
already didn't know okay anything else
did he look set in y'all nope
out you come you sexy sexy thing and
then we go back downstairs to the guy in
the server room intentional all right
sir I think that I have to find a way to
talk this guy into letting me fix it or
letting me stay in there or something
so that I can intercept something from
Domino I believe so I can like steal yes
okay he's back this is totally what I
was meant to do I bet people make this
mistake all the time or at least that's
what I'm telling myself look we had
camera [ __ ] what's that
nothing would watch hey buddy
hey I'm still not getting any messages
nothing what how am I supposed to get in
here
maybe if I like threaten to use the
extinguisher can I keep the door open
Oh oh my god that's so simple is that is
that really all I needed to do I okay
let's give it a try let's leave
okay yeah surely surely that's it okay
let's get out of you and see what
happens you won't notice that the doors
are locked and it'll stay open ah yes
oh my god that was a complete fluke holy
[ __ ]
walk back in here let's do it
okay and now I should be able to take
the douchebags message yes so
interesting graphics that it's a red
tube what it's locked
can I break it with something maybe
like I know this thing says the same
thing all the time but I'm compelled to
try it smash it
everyone just think that it's just
damaged red stick saloon scythe playing
cards let's give that a try oh maybe
maybe I can oh yes yes oh my god oh oh
too much air pressure so that's totally
it
oh my god i I'm so what's gonna pick
those cards up um too much air pressure
okay maybe if we do like one of the ones
so it's not completely broken but it's
half broken that'll affect air pressure
and we slot a card in and everything is
it's so bad Oh little junior sales
associate you all right I'm gonna walk
up this street no [ __ ] worm what is
this well as a clown even doing like
standing outside the wrong side of the
[ __ ] thing like surely I'm the only
one visiting him like Wrigley yeah we go
I don't know why if I press press X
there it walks and we're going to that
side for whatever reason probably for
the birds but I think I probably have to
do something with them later okay
another dead worm
well sure Lou thank you a good service
control help oh there is director's
commentary that's awesome use item talk
scoop dialogue examine item I just
didn't even think that it would have
this because it didn't have a tutorial
or anything Ron let's do it let's see
how fast he goes oh my god I'm so sorry
to watch me walk everywhere oh this is
terrible
oh my god it's so much faster god damn
pulling away wait did he just say it's
closed the building's closed no okay no
they will never be closed I will just
run through it ah that was like my only
complaint to this entire game and it has
been fixed by me looking at [ __ ]
control scheme because I got being so
goddamn slow and really it was my fault
okay so maybe maybe it the reason why it
let me do the same thing twice and have
the secured sorry so the guy back in
there wasn't actually because a lot of
people screw up it's just me
maybe it's because yeah you have to do
this you have to screw it up again so
like one and a half times for something
something air pressure
and you can get the message you like to
keep it again yeah you pop that in there
all right
I feel good about that and it's like
almost the right side the side where the
red stuff is too so let's go to get out
of here money let's do it
I'm excited things are gonna happen for
us you know it's our big day you know
okay you said to walk a little bit
further
all right run everywhere okay so it's
obviously like freaking out phoner
that's right I need the the card yes
come on what oh my god I have no idea
what to do then yeah
too much aunt pressure do I fix air
pressure okay so could I do something to
do with the buds now I what